hey guys let's talk about sunglasses
what are the best sunglasses for men to
buy when it comes to style and shape
well this depends on what you want to
use your sunglasses for and also your
face shape because certain sunglasses
will look great on certain face shapes
and not so great on others so let me
take some time let me quickly explain
this to you and then you'll know for the
rest of your life let's not waste any
more time let's get to it
now just very quick if it's the first
time that you're here my name is daniel
and welcome to dlm men's lifestyle
consider subscribing also clicking that
notification bell so you won't miss any
of our future videos now let's talk
about the shape first when it comes to
sunglasses
it's always better to wear the opposite
shaped sunglasses
of your face shape for example if you
have a hard face shape it will look good
with round style glasses club masters
might also be a good option a round face
shape will definitely not look good with
round glasses so just get the opposite
you need glasses that will give you more
definition like square sunglasses
wayfarers and club masters are good
options then a square face shape will
look better with round or oval
sunglasses so stay away from angular
designs aviators for example will look
great
and then a long or rectangular face
shape is similar to a square shaped face
meaning you need round shapes an oval
face shape if you have an oval face
shape you are blessed because you can
almost put on any shape of sunglasses
and you will still look good an oval
face usually also comes with a good
strong jawline well it depends on person
to person but in most cases that is true
but in case your face shape looks closer
to a round face then you need more
definition just like a round face so
stay away from round sunglasses and go
for square shapes all right i think i
just covered all the face shapes out
there
yes all right let's move on let's go to
all the best types of sunglasses that
you can buy but please remember these
are just my own favorite preferences
for fashion
the hexagonal flat lenses from ray-ban
they look super stylish and that's well
that's all you need to know other
glasses that also look great are any
sunglasses from serengeti they are like
the royals royce of sunglasses personal
aviator sunglasses
randolph engineering concord classic
aviator sunglasses
diff kodi sunglasses
warby parker hatcher sunglasses and of
course ray-ban classic aviator
sunglasses now just remember i will add
all the direct links for you in the
video description so it's easier for you
to go and check them out
now if you are on a budget you can try
these plus s premium military style
classic aviator sunglasses or the
sunguide vintage round sunglasses
next up sport if you are into sport and
you're looking for the best sunglasses
go for the nike hyper force or you can
also check out the rafa pro team
flyweight glasses if you ride bikes
or if you like swimming try the maui gym
world cup sunglasses or the oakley split
shot if you love fishing like i do
and then if you are on a budget you can
also try out gear district polarized uv
400 sports sunglasses for any outdoor
activity and then if you just want nice
glasses while driving the ones that i
really like are the american optical
original pilot other good options are
the ray-ban rb43335
and for a budget the person driving
sunglasses on amazon
now give me your favorite pair of
sunglasses in the comment section down
below and if you want to know how to
determine your face shape and watch this
video here and it will help you out i'll
see you there and before you go always
remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys